there's a chef sir often I know he's in
the back he's in the back is he choking
off no so he's here but he's not cooking
hmm I would really like to meet the
executive chef chef Bryan Rutherford
Goran Ramsey how are you let's go
somewhere out there no legalized oh yes
I'm lost for words I just I don't know I
didn't know where to start and why would
you cook for me why wouldn't you do that
it's not a question of me not cooking
for you it's do you want to see what
we're doing here because I want this to
improve you've been here for how long
five years five years so you've been
cooking for 30 83 years 33 years I
didn't see you on the line I didn't see
you taste anything to see you I didn't
even see you inspire anybody
this position is killing me in my soul
I've just been doing everything that
Eddie wanted we have two large menus or
the amount of business we do samaya 120
items on the menu and we do 50 people a
night how much of this am i able to prep
on a regular basis to have quality but
you're the executive chef on the menu
yes I am how do you let that food go out
with your name above it you can't just
give up for almost zero abandon ship
before it's sunk
I'm at the end of your toast I'm tired
for your you're an experienced guy you
okay
look at me look at me the standards you
okay are your medication
excuse me can you get me some water
please quickly and give me a chair
please
a chair
cool 9-1-1 please quickly 9-1-1 jeez
come here
Jesus Christ urgently what happened
chefs on the floor [ __ ]
you ok cool 9-1-1 chef just fell
collapse can I have some water please
and a cold cloth it's urgently to try
stay low
Brian I was with the gentleman we were
to Standish talking and unfortunately
just slapped some Bank his head on the
back here I am really pissed off at
Gordon he's stressing everybody out
everyone seems to be at their boiling
point because he been stressed out for
long I mean there's been a lot of stress
on all of us but me being here yeah but
do not dare [ __ ] go anywhere near
that I put him in that ambulance yeah
let me tell you something 150 items on a
[ __ ] menu the size of a [ __ ]
shoebox cuz then that man to an early
grave let me tell you it's like he's a
dead man walking what he tried to tell
me in a five-minute conversation is that
you've overburdened him because he does
whatever you want do you pay salary but
you're not behind that line you have no
catering experience you haven't spent a
day in a kitchen I've never seen
anything so fragmented okay it's like
you're a little magpie a little spoilt
[ __ ] magpie that's going around
picking out a little bits of litter and
running back and get your army to
expedite it for you all that matters
right now is that guy wakes up to more
feelin better
enough there's enough for one day yeah